The Hollywood Reporter says President  Trump attacked Jimmy Fallon for  regretting his famous appearance on The  Tonight Show  Fallon choked up during the podcast last  week talking about the criticism he  received for tossing mr. Trump's hair in  September 2016 you go all right we get  it  I heard you right do you made me feel  bad so now what are you happy yeah I'm  depressed you want to push me more what  do all we did I know what you should I  mean it you let me kill myself what  would make you happy get over it  well in her tweet yesterday the  president told Fallon be a man Jimmy he  claims that Fallon called him after the  show to brag about the monster ratings  for the interview